if all you want to do is just answer
questions then you can check out now you
can start off on your exercise if you
like but I'm going to dig a little bit
deeper now to help me understand is what
you need is um three pins
I'm gonna and we're just using these
pins to give us a bit of a model for
what this thing looks like okay you're
gonna need some pins and you'll also
need something you still need to keep
drawing okay so I'm sorry now I want you
to look at this simplified bottle for a
second and there's a big glaring problem
with us in the flight model and in fact
it's kind of the way we simplified it
you know the this joke about the
physicist in the spherical count the way
that we've simplified allows us to solve
the question but unfortunately I feel
you can judge for yourself when we get
the information I feel this the way we
simplified it the specific way we
simplified it actually sort of pulls the
rug out from underneath why not just the
cyclist can incline so they can do it
but in fact the cyclists must inclined
otherwise they can't successfully make
the turn okay what was the
simplification I started off with to
actually make this model work the
cyclist is a point okay and I had to do
that because that's the only tools that
I have to deal with at the moment
okay and I said to you I alluded to the
fact that when you don't consider a
point before even just on one dimension
the forces get super super crazy okay so
I want you to imagine this guy here
right as an object and it has
it hasn't away okay I won't even worry
about two dimensions at the moment
because this object has a length now as
with real estate when you consider the
forces it's all about location location
location right so I want you to I asked
you for three parents right so I've got
this one in the middle which represents
an object then I've got two other ones
that represent forces okay now if what I
do is I have these forces sort of
opposing each other same like you learn
to draw something like this if you're
like opposing each other
same leg and they're at the same point
okay tell me what is the net force on
this object net force is zero great
everything is balanced out okay I could
if I can move them about that - okay
that's fine if I've got a single point
and it's just they're obviously still
been force to her okay but if I change
the locations of these forces okay like
this what is the net force now the net
he's ready to add a new concept it's all
very distinguished so if I would just
say that course and we're like well
that's the only kind of force the
readers right I'm gonna say there's a
net linear force here it's a net linear
force this is still headed up this is
still headed down the directions have
not changed and they're quite their
magnitudes haven't changed so if I just
added up linear linearize I'll still get
0 okay but the net torque you won't yes
the net torque is not zero because of
course right what does this mean what
does this mean if I start it and you've
got this on your page I insist that you
actually physically do this with me
right as you push what happens it turns
right it must turn so tor means a force
then imparts not linear velocity but
angular velocity okay so toys the
special name we give to something which
is going to 210 something towards
rotation
okay no understanding the cyclists
torque is
everything that's what this whole
situation is about okay because it is in
fact the fact that like I picked this
out not accidentally it's because the
south coast has right right that is what
makes this actually complicated right
which is why as well if you see um if
you see trucks like semi trailers and
they will sometimes have what they're
indicating is because some semi trailers
are really really tall they are so tall
that talk forces are actually
influencing it can make these things tip
over right
it's the hunch it's the hype that really
matters right so considering this is
just the point kind of take the heart
and soul out of what makes the mechanics
work okay so I just want to quickly show
you these and these might be kind of
like the diagrams you you might want to
have
oh I unplugged that's right okay so
these are the cases that I just went
through so it's important to have some
diagnose that look like this right if
you've got opposite and equal forces on
a point others if you got opposite equal
forces on the same point in an object
still no problem but if you move them
through other positions that's when you
add angular momentum okay is one other
thing you need to worry about which I
could draw it up but I'm just going to
show you this okay two things actually
where where you put things is important
right so the further you are away if
there's like some fixed point which must
rotate I get for instance you know the
hands of a clock okay there's a point
that stays put and the rest of it can
move okay the further you are away from
that point that fixed point of rotation
the more torque is actually put in and
that makes sense if you think about this
is the way that um this is the way that
leave is and like span is and that kind
of thing work it's like look if I'm over
here I don't have to apply much force at
all if I have a really really long
spanner to make
t-turn if I got something short like
wanting this awkward allocation you have
to hold it the wrong way you could put
heaps of force in it hurts your fingers
and all that kind of thing okay so this
is the way that talks autumn is
proportional there's one more important
thing that should worth writing down
which is this guy over here if you've
got some fix point let's call it o
because everything is going to be
rotating around that right if you have a
force that is at oh that's a turn or
it's directed to water then they don't
exert any torque just think about that
for a second right for example have a
look at my arm at the turning heads of
the clock okay
if you exerted force at the end of the
hand of course it will spin around
that's fine
but if you exert a force at the center
of the clock it's not gonna spin nothing
will happen no matter which way you
point it okay and in the same way in
fact once you can pull it down because
of you
okay so I've said if I push me up if I
push you up it's not gonna rotate right
in the same way if I push this way or I
push this way of course there's notation
but if I push along the hand of the
clock right so I'm pushing here I'm
pushing at a point that's not the center
but if I direct my force toward the
center like that up the axis of the hand
what rotation is going to happen and
it's a nun so that's why they don't
exert any torque and that's actually
really a really important point okay I
tried to boil it down as cyclic AMP
forces at or directed toward the center
of rotation they observe it okay that's
all the pieces that we need now we're
ready to consider this cyclist